misogyny is not “hating women”
that's a completely useless definition that's actually counterproductive
and all it does is help sustain the patriarchy
let me explain describing misogyny as hating women
eliminates our ability to actually diagnose anything that we see in front of us
as being misogynistic for a few different reasons
let's use Donald Trump as an example
so if you say Donald Trump is a misogynist
first of all you can't get inside his head
how are you going to prove that internally he hates women
second there are women that he loves
he loves manga women he probably loves his wife
he loves women who he's attracted to
he loves women who help him further his goals
and he just generally
loves women who behave accordingly to gendered and societal role misogyny
and all this is Kate Mannes’ Down Girl
which I highly recommend
is more productively understood as a political phenomenon
it should be understood as a system that operates within a patriarchal
social order
to police and enforce women's subordination and to uphold male dominance
it's a system that is policing people
into behaving within their gendered norms and expectations
and it's policing people to continue to uphold the patriarchy
misogynist can love their mothers
not to mention their sisters daughters
wives girlfriends
secretaries they need not hate women universally
or even very generally they tend to hate women who are outspoken
action was all about misogyny
and that doesn't mean that people went into the voting booth thinking
I hate women
what it was is that this election was policing people's gender norms
it was ensuring that um
trans individuals can't get healthcare
ensuring that women across the United States perform reproductive duties about
um making sure that a woman didn't have authority over men
so much more um
I have so much to say about this topic because this is such an incredible book
I am the feminist lawyer follow me if you enjoy being miserable